[Musique]
si vous pensez que rien ne se passe dans
les collèges de l'île avant la rentrée
c'est mal connaître les 1206 att e
adjoint technique territorial des
établissements d'enseignement du
département collège henri-matisse que le
mail et en actions pour préparer la
rentrée dans les meilleures vies
quand on arrive dans on nettoie donc on
fait tout le service général quand les
élèves arrivent bien il trouve quelque
chose de propre
donc pour travailler je pense que c'est
mieux pour eux et surtout l'hygiène pour
réaliser les bosses et un cadre agréable
pour améliorer le climat scolaire est
clairement l'objectif sans oublier
l'hygiène et la sécurité dans un
complexe d'épidémie de dengue
déjà on sent mieux des gens tombent pas
malades c'est une bonne chose parce que
moi j'ai eu la dengue
c'est pas lui dans donc fonctionnel
j'étais bloqué donc et puis pour les
élèves c'est plus agréable d'être dans
un cadre propre
il n'y a pas le moustique ou au chant
jazz comme ça ils peuvent travailler
tranquillement cet établissement
connaîtra à cette rentrée plusieurs
modifications
un nouveau plan d'accès du nouveau
matériel et même nouveau gymnase
renoncer en partie par la collectivité
de tutelle des collèges pas ça il ya
très stable evans chef dont il avoue
qu'il y ait sa part aux faciliter la
mise en place et aussi le comme ça au
niveau de l'hygiène des sables des
agents plus avec les nouvelles
vous maniez voyage facile et cela voyez
bien ça fait des années et des années
que cet établissement a envie avec des
plateaux fortement exposés donc ça veut
dire que des élèves
comptant à faire leurs activités et des
professeurs également content est ravi
de les accompagner
on aura une interaction extrêmement
positive qui va se mettre en oeuvre et
nul doute que cela va accroître
l'ambition des élèves
montrez vous verse actuellement dans
toute l'île ces hommes et ces femmes
font tout ce qu'il faut pour offrir à
nos enfants un cadre idéal
d'épanouissement les élèves bas bonne
rentrée à tous et aux professeurs et
puis à bas tous les personnels de
l'éducation
[Musique]